Oh, shit.
Sorry, I forgot.
Sorry, my thing is still on my Uber Eats app.
Oh.
All right.
Bad news.
I'm sick.
I know.
Yet again.
It's so hard being the perfect human being.
No way.
I don't know how... I don't know how I went outside, you know, for my dog.
And then I got sick coming back.
I don't know how that happened.
I literally was outside.
Well, I was outside for a while.
But I touched grass.
And then, poof, I'm sick now.
I have...
So, I don't know how I'm going to be streaming today.
Because I do have my sponsor stream later today.
Yeah.
Will you stop drinking dad's vital fluids?
No!
I don't have easy access to the cure anymore.
Like they say, the owner reflects their pet.
But yes.
Yes.
Last night, I felt like...
The sore throat thing.
I felt it.
And then...
I'm sick to...
Twinsies!
Oh, my God!
It's so good to be sick together.
Dark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Last night, I felt...
You know, like when you feel a tingling on your sore throat.
You feel that tingle.
And you know that like...
The moment your sore throat tingles...
You know that you're about to get sick.
And then, so like...
I prepped everything.
Like I prepped my humidifier.
I prepped...
Like I wet a towel.
And then put it on the side of my bed.
And then I woke up.
And my nose is so stuffy.
And...
You know, my throat...
Feels a lot better.
It doesn't hurt as much anymore.
It doesn't hurt anymore.
So like...
I hope that continues.
I hope my throat continues to be...
Okay.
And...
Uh...
Yeah.
So I just have my stuffy nose.
I'm gonna be blowing my nose a lot.
But that means I'm gonna be muting myself.
Blowing my nose a lot.
Because you guys don't get access to that.
No, no, no.
Um, Nettie.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Rate the soup.
I was thinking whether or not to...
Reschedule today's stream.
But then I was like...
You know what?
Let's see how I go.
If I...
If I die, die.
If I get more sick...
It's on me.
I took the risk.
I took the 50-50.
I was like...
It won't be that bad.
Like...
Get the...
You know...
It's all...
It's all about gambling.
Let's go gambling with my health.
Kanye East.
Thank you for this Magenta Soup.
Thank you.
For the soup funds.
And Doki Healthcare funds.
Thank you for Magenta Soup.
Thank you.
Okay.
My gacha luck in gacha is not great.
But like...
In real life...
It's...
Also not that great.
But...
But it's gonna turn around right now.
Today's the day where it turns around.
Robbins.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you still putting minerals in the humidifier?
No.
I boiled...
Oh.
Fuck.
I forgot.
My humidifier might have been just boiled water.
I forgot about that.
Fuck.
Okay.
That's fine.
It might have been boiled water.
Boiled tap water.
It's been a while.
All right.
Okay.
It'll only go up from here.
Starting now.
Aphelion.
Thank you for the five gifted chips.
Thank you.
The gacha gods are in your favor.
Thank you for the super chat, Joel.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
Life update.
Also, not so Deadpool.
Thank you for the gifted chips.
Thank you.
Life update.
Oh, fuck.
What was the life update?
Give me a sec.
I'm...
It was in my head.
And then it disappeared.
Yags, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
Oh, my God.
What was this life update that I had to give you guys?
Was it important?
It could have been important.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Um...
Oh, my God.
It was, like, something related to, like, something I have to be...
I'll be doing later.
But, like, I don't remember right now.
Oh, no.
This is bad.
Okay.
I told myself...
All right, Doki.
Remember to talk about this on stream.
Um...
You don't need to write this down.
I...
It'll be fine.
You don't need to write this down.
I'm like, you're right, brain.
I don't need to write this down.
Um...
Yags, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
Music.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy to be watching on my birthday today.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you, too.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear music.
Yeah!
I just remembered it.
Because I just saw the $3 million prize pool from Marvel Rivals for, like, pro players.
Um...
Anyway.
To segue from that.
It's actually crazy that they're putting in $3 million right away for Marvel Rivals.
Like, competitive e-sports team.
Um...
Just because, like...
The amount of money they made just from cosmetics alone.
Like, it...
It shows you how much money they made from farming people off of cosmetics.
Off of cosmetics.
If they are just able to drop $3 million just right off the bat for their first LAN.
Because you guys don't know.
That's the LAN.
Because it's a world...
Um...
It's a world tournament.
So, like...
That's gonna be a LAN thing later on.
Uh...
So, yeah.
Like, hey.
$3 million off the bat for LAN.
For their very first LAN.
Is absolutely insane.
But that's, like...
I guess that's NetEase being like...
Yeah, we made that much money off of you guys!
We made so much money off of you guys!
That $3 million is nothing!
Anyway.
The segue...
Off of that...
Um...
I got invited to the XQC Marvel Rivals tournament.
That's, like, the $250k...
Um...
The $250k dollars one.
That's gonna be somewhere in May.
I don't remember.
Um...
But, like, a huge shout-out to...
A huge shout-out to...
The Marvel Rivals does.
For, like, actually getting me in.
I asked about it.
Because I saw the...
Article about it.
I saw the...
Um...
Article...
About the tournament.
Because I saw XQC talking about it.
And then, like, people made articles.
Being like, oh, yeah.
XQC...
Um...
Is gonna be hosting this.
And I was like, oh, that's cool.
I want me in it.
And then I...
DM'd my...
Marvel Rivals staff person.
That I'm connected with.
Um...
And I asked, like...
Oh, yeah.
Can I be...
Can I be, like...
Uh...
On...
Can I, like, join the tournament?
And then they were like...
Yeah.
We're gonna put...
And then they were like...
Yeah.
We're gonna ask...
Um...
The XQC tournament, uh...
Team...
If we could get you in.
And, um...
They messaged me back.
And they were telling me, like...
Yeah.
You're on, like...
On top of our priority list.
Um...
And, like...
Uh...
They're gonna...
They're gonna, like...
Contact you.
And then you'll be in the tournament.
And I was like...
Yippee!
And then yesterday...
Like, the...
One of the...
Um...
One of the people organizing the tournament...
Messaged me yesterday.
Um...
Being like...
Yeah.
Uh...
We're looking forward to seeing you in the tournament.
We're gonna provide you with more info later on...
Um...
The next couple of the days.
So I think I'm confirmed to be in it.
Like...
I'm gonna take that as the confirmation.
If, like...
The head guy that's organizing the tournament...
Like, literally messaged...
Added me on Discord.
And messaged me.
And told me that they're gonna give me more info later.
So, I hope so.
Oh, you know what's funny?
Okay, what's funny is that... Apparently, there's some pro players that really wanted to be involved in XTC's tournament because it's $250,000.
Yeah, that's a lot of money.
But they've, like, barred any pro players from joining the tournament.
Like, any active Marvel Rivals pros joining it.
And then, it's funny because, like, one of my friends was saying how there were some teams that were, like, crashing out about it.
And they were like, it's $250,000!
This was before the $3 million... This was before the $3 million thing was announced.
And they were like, they're like, what are these streamers gonna do with $200,000?
They were like... My friend was like, the rich gets richer.
I thought... I thought that was a bit funny.
Because they're... It's like... Apparently, some teams were, like, crashing out about it because they were like, let me in!
Let me in!
No, no, this is a different... XQC's tournament is $250,000.
The Marvel Rivals eSport LAN, the first LAN, is $3 million.
So, it's different.
I thought that was, like... I thought that was funny.
Because, like, they're like, let me in!
We want to be in it, too!
But, apparently, from what I was told, and what other people told me, is that the tournament is gonna be, like, streamer only.
Streamer only.
So, like, no active pros in the Rivals scene will be part of the...
part of the XQC tournament.
So, I don't know who else is gonna be in it.
I just know I'm in it.
Like, I...
Well, obviously, XQC is also gonna be in it, too.
Because it's his tournament.
But, other than that, I just know I'm in it.
Like, I don't know who else.
I don't know the format yet.
I'll probably find out about it, like, later in a couple of days.
I don't even remember what day it's supposed to be.
Let me look that up.
Literally, the only thing I know about it is from, like, random...
like, Dexter or some shit.
XQC, Marvel, Rivals...
I need to, like, mark that off.
Okay, it's on May 9th, technically.
Okay, it's next week.
Oh, my God.
I didn't even realize it was gonna be next week.
Okay, let me mark this off for myself.
I don't know what time it's gonna be.
I just know it's somewhere on the 9th.
XQC, Marvel, Rivals, Tournament.
Let me mark that off real fast for myself so I don't forget.
XQC... I need to write this again.
Marvel, Rivals, Tournament.
So I have to start playing Rivals again in a couple of...
I guess, like, now.
XQC, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Remember, Master Ui's wise words.
Monkey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No name.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I know you hate Rocket, but $3 billion.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I think I'm like randomly placed in a team, I'm pretty sure.
Because like, I mean, it's next week, so like, we'll see how this is going to be like by then.
Daddy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Ah, yes, Bloons, where I belong.
Hello, Doki Bird, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I've actually never played Bloons before.
Is that crazy?
I've never, okay, today, I was deciding between Plants vs.
Zombies or Bloons, because I've never played either of those games before, so I don't know what it's gonna be like going in.
I just never played the game.
I know like, people in Overwatch used to play Bloons to, to like, wait out the queue and stuff, and the queues are too long.
But like, other than that, I've never actually, um, played this game before, so I'm, I have no idea going in.
I know like, you're like a monk, you put monkeys in, and you shoot like air, like, what is it?
Balloons?
It's like tower defense, right?
Uh, basically, right guys?
Uh, Alan, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
But Doki, what are you going to eat for?
They have their $3 million, and there we just got announced today.
They have their $3 million tournament, they don't need this $250k.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, thank you.
All right.
All right, let's see.
I need that $250k prize pool for, for that, that surgery.
For the fucking dog surgery I had.
Like, like, I take what I can get now.
All right, let me, uh, get the audio in.
Uh, bloons.
All right.
Pop, pop, pop.
All right, sound guy, let me know if it's okay.
Um, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I still remember that one clip of you smoking him.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Pop, pop, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
The bloons have taken over the town.
Okay.
Stop the bloons from getting through.
Oh, is this a tutorial?
All right.
And then place another dart monkey.
Where do I place him?
I guess I'll place him here.
I'll place him in the front.
Wait, is that smart?
Well, time to find out.
Right in the day.
Doki, you're not supposed to place that monkey there.
One hundred bloons versus one monkey.
Uh, Black, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
It's not 250k, but I hope this helps with the vent bells and hope Dad recovers well.
Thank you, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
All right.
I mean, that seems pretty easy.
When does this get hard?
Famous last words.
Earns you a monkey experience.
All right.
Your dart monkeys have enough to unlock an upgrade.
Let's see.
First stream ever and it be on my birthday?
Thank you for the super chat, Yags.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Yags.
Yeah.
All right.
Can pop shoot...
Can pop one extra balloon?
Makes the dart monkeys shoot further than normal?
Maybe like...
Extra balloon?
I feel like...
Oh, but then the 15% means I can do like four.
All right.
I'll need an extra one.
Wait, I'll do it.
And then I'll do 15% later.
Oh, I have to upgrade this myself as well?
Oh.
All right.
There you go.
It's fine.
My monkeys can do it.
Go monkeys, go.
Need some help?
Quincy is a monkey hero that upgrades himself during that game.
He can pop several balloons per shot.
Oh wait.
Get in here, Quincy.
There you go.
Oh my god.
You sound like an adult.
Candy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dark Blade, thank you for the super chat.
Doki's sick again because she went outside again.
Doki never learns.
Stop going outside.
You know outside, bad.
Outside, evil.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll never learn.
Why don't I learn that outside is bad?
All right.
Upgrade more?
All right, let's... I get that, actually.
The quickshot?
Does it travel over?
Do my upgrades travel over?
Oh my god, you know he's good when he has a bandana on his head.
All right.
There's no... You're right, there's no bloons outside.
What's the point?
Does it carry over?
Oh.
Choose a monkey to unlock?
With my ice monkey?
I hear ice monkey is pretty good.
I see a lot of art about ice monkey.
All right, ice monkey.
You go here.
All right, do your thing, ice monkey.
Should I put it here?
Oh, maybe I should put it down here.
I'm learning.
Anyone is a good choice.
I always see so much about ice monkey.
I'll put him here, too.
All right, there we go.
What is he doing?
Ice monkey, do something!
I'm just too good.
I'm too good that ice monkey can't even do anything.
You have activated ability.
They create powerful temporary effects to help you win.
Choose carefully when you use them.
However, as each one has a cooldown...
Where's my ability?
Where is it?
How do I use it?
Where ability at?
Where is it?
What?
Lego.
Lord.
I'm sorry, not Lego.
Lord, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, it's on... Oh, is it this?
Oh, that's... That's what it is.
Okay.
I don't think I need to do any... Oh, okay.
All right, use your ability.
I want to see.
Okay, we did it.
One round ago.
I don't think I need to do anything.
Oh, wait.
Did he use it?
Oh, that was a waste.
I didn't know it was over!
I was just... I was just...
Blooning!
Also, how's the sound, guys?
Ice Monkey is so cool.
What's... He's just bluer!
What makes him cooler than the other monkeys?
He's just more blue.
All right.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
I got monkey money.
Oh, my God.
Wait, is this gacha?
Wait.
Is this...
Is this pay to win?
Did I accidentally play a game where I have to pay to win?
No?
Oh, that's good.
I was like, wait.
This has, like...
This is so, like, gacha-pilled.
Like, the...
The...
You know, like, when you know a microtransaction?
Yeah, like...
This menu is so...
Like, you can tell this was a microtransaction game.
Like...
You can...
You can just tell.
Yeah, the UI.
Um, interesting.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just got over my fear of monkeys after my cat.
What?
Anyway, what are you...
Just turned into the stream to the line.
What are you playing?
I'm playing balloons.
All right.
I don't remember if anyone said anything about the sound, but...
I don't see anyone talking about the sound anymore.
So, I think it's okay.
We mouse-holded by the power of Battle Cat.
I can take him on.
You see, many portals appear in our world.
So, after the appear...
I...
You know what?
I went to the unusual readings were detected near Adora's temple.
So, I rushed over to set up more.
Um, I've done the calculations.
Uh, and the riff will appear very soon.
Something very fast.
Unfortunately, balloons seems as sensitive and they're about to attack.
Can you please manage the defense while I gather more data?
I think I can take him on.
I just finished the tutorial.
Um...
Where are these other monkeys?
How much money are you?
Uh...
Oh, whoops.
Stop.
Oh, I already fucked it up.
I got confused.
I got confused, okay?
I got really confused, okay?
What do these other monkeys do?
I don't know.
There's so many monkeys.
Which monkey does... Oh, gun.
Gun monkey must be really good.
Right?
Gun monkey go pew pew, I believe.
Okay, gun monkey...
He looks cool.
And then...
You look cool, too.
But I can't put you anywhere.
Alright.
Boomerang monkey, you look cool.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, that's a lot.
I think I'm doing it, guys.
Look at that.
I'm doing it.
Wait, how do you move monkeys?
Please.
Okay.
Now they're coming here.
And...
Oh...
You look cool.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is fine.
This should be fine.
Yeah.
We're doing it.
I believe.
Oh, okay.
I believe less.
I still believe.
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Things are going okay.
Wait, where will they go now?
Wait.
Enhance.
Freeze.
I'm...
My head is trying to figure this out.
Oh.
Guys.
It may or may...
Oh, wait.
No, it's not over yet.
Wait.
We're okay.
22 rounds?
What the hell?
Uh...
And then...
Bloon.
Okay.
22 rounds.
It's fine.
Where's Quincy?
Where is he?
Oh, no.
Okay.
No, it's still working.
Whatever's happening.
It's even...
The dimensional field line are converging.
Like...
Another universe is approaching.
Oh, we can't stop it.
We can stop the Bloons from...
Hold them off a little.
Oh.
I have every...
Ninja.
Ninja looks cool.
He look cool.
Okay.
Far.
Alright.
There we go.
We have...
He look cool.
Why...
Why is Ninja not doing anything?
Ninja.
Why aren't you doing...
Why did Ninja not do anything?
Oh, he only kills this balloon.
He's out of...
Ninja.
Why are you out of reach?
Okay.
This is fine.
Um...
I have...
Boat.
No, I don't have boat.
I have...
Monkey?
Monkey number two.
I believe.
You can't fuck this up for me.
Oh, I'm dead.
Alright.
Let's...
Let's do the tutorial.
Let us...
Let us do the regular game.
Guys.
I got...
Very...
Let's just...
Let's just play...
Monkey metal.
Monkey metal sounds nice.
Let's go easy.
Yeah.
Monkey metal.
Monkey...
Alright.
Okay.
That's fine.
Now I feel more safe.
I feel...
I feel very safe now.
Wow.
This...
This feels...
Much easier.
Than whatever the fuck I just went through.
Alright.
Nice.
Yay.
Monkey metal.
Oh my god.
Yay, Quincy.
Guys.
Why did you make me do that?
Why?
Guys.
Why did you make me do such a hard level?
Wait.
40 rounds?
Jesus Christ.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
I didn't realize there were more to this.
I will do that.
And then we'll upgrade you.
And I think Quincy's already...
This is a group effort.
Alright.
I'll save up for Ice Monkey.
I feel like Ice Monkey is pretty good.
I can't always save up for Ice Monkey.
Alright.
Yay.
There's always a group.
I'm level four!
Let's do the attack shooter.
I want Ice Monkey.
Ice Monkey seems like he knows what he's doing.
Because he's blue.
And he controls...
He literally controls the elements.
He is a superhero at this point.
Alright, Ice Monkey.
You go here.
And then I'm gonna give you this.
Wait.
Yeah.
Let you upgrade that.
Alright.
Clap!
Clap for me, Ice Monkey!
Yeah, he's literally...
Well, he's not the avatar.
He can control one element.
Um...
This on circular spots?
Like here?
Well, it's not really...
It's half a circle.
But I can't really move them anymore.
Alright.
Clap!
Ice Monkey!
Clap for our enjoyment!
Do your thing!
Oh, wait.
This game is so easy.
When does this get hard?
Oh, shit!
I accidentally...
Castle try almost unlock all.
I...
It would be funny.
I would just pay to win there.
Oh, just...
He's...
Now I don't remember.
It seems like a...
Game for children.
Alright, let's see.
Do I need permafrost?
I feel like I don't need that.
I feel like...
As long as he can clap...
Things will be okay.
Alright, speed this up for me.
This game is too easy.
Speed...
I want it to be faster.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
Come on.
Do your thing.
Alright.
Guys, like Doki Keeper.
It says...
Don't mention...
What's mobs?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh!
Under the settings?
To make it...
Alright, give me Boomerang Monkey.
Wait, what?
This?
Oh.
Does it go faster?
I wanna start.
Why is it still so slow?
I thought you said this goes faster.
Oh, it popped.
You know what?
Two.
Make him strong.
Make my monkey strong!
Bottom right?
Yeah.
I'm going as fast as I can.
This is so easy.
Wait.
This round never stopped.
Wait, wait a minute.
Shit, wait a minute.
I think now I realize what it means when rounds are on.
Guys, I think I understand what you mean now.
Oh, wait a minute.
Okay.
No, it's fine.
These key art will regrow back gloss layers every couple of seconds.
It's fine.
Things are fine.
My blue...
My monkeys are so strong.
I have nothing to worry about.
I have strong monkeys.
Okay.
Unlock these too.
Alright.
Oh my god, he's so cool!
He has glasses!
He's so cool.
There you go.
I don't know how to do anything here.
Are small yet containing two pinks inside them.
Also, black bloons are immune to explosions.
Alright, nice.
Wait, I can put boomerang bloons now.
I'll put boomerang bloons here.
Alright.
And then...
Uh...
Oh shit.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh fuck, wait a minute.
Let me...
Let me slow things down a little bit!
Wait.
Wait, you guys.
Let me...
Let me slow things down a little...
A little bit.
Okay.
Um...
I just realized that...
Things got a little faster.
Okay, upgrade.
Up to eight bloons?
Okay, we want that.
Oh my god, he's wearing red.
Okay, and then we'll do that.
Alright, there you go.
Can it be affected unless they have a way to detect him?
For example, Quincy can be at level five with enhanced eyesight.
Wait, wait, wait, wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute.
What does enhanced eyesight mean?
Wait, wait, give me a sec.
I need an... oh, there we go.
Okay, we gotta upgrade this.
Okay, uh... Wait, path plus...
Okay,
there we go.
Not closed anymore.
Okay.
Okay, it's not closed anymore.
That's good.
Alright, we have one guy.
We have a bonus guy.
Okay.
Can pop more bloons even.
Yeah, we want that.
And long range.
Let's do that.
Uh... If we ever need it.
I can also build ninja?
I don't have ninja though.
I'm just level seven.
I'm just a tiny little monkey.
Oh!
Wait, sniper monkey can see camo.
He's wearing camo, right?
Wait, but plain monkey.
Oh my god.
The sky.
Wait, no.
I got the sky with me.
I'm gonna save up for the... I'm gonna save up for plain monkey.
I have the... I have the sky.
They combine the meanest of white bloons and black bloons and contain one... Oh wait.
I can do him.
Go!
My... My aircraft!
They made a meadow so it can be hurt by tribe bombs.
Wait, what?
Wait.
Oh.
Is this bomb?
I...
Is this... Is this... Oh shit!
I got... Oh shit!
I got... I got... I got confused!
Oh come on.
Oh!
I was like...
What bomb?
What?
What makes it go...
I got... I got confused.
Oh.
Okay, glue monkey.
You can't...
Tell me.
Alright.
It's okay.
Things are fine now.
Things are fine.
Uh.
You know what?
I want pineapple.
There we go.
Um.
Oh shit.
Okay, I need...
Please.
I need a...
I need money.
Please.
I... I need money.
Oh no.
Okay.
There we go.
Extra range.
There.
Things will be fine, guys.
I have pineapple.
Is this...
I think this position is pretty good.
I think...
Alright.
Now we unlock sniper monkey.
Okay.
Here we go.
There we go.
I figured it out, guys.
Now I have range.
I have range, guys.
I figured it out.
And then...
Shoots faster.
Darts can pop.
You know what?
Yeah.
Too faster.
Okay.
Um.
XP?
I have XP.
How much XP does my dart monkey have?
Oh, fuck.
Fuck up.
Ah.
I have...
My brain.
Yes.
Okay.
Nice.
Can't...
Ah.
Fuck.
Brain.
Brain hurt.
Anybody share sims?
Thank you.
This is super chat.
Okay.
Sniper.
Sniper!
Sniper, right here.
It's fine.
Just a couple more.
No, it's okay.
I got it.
I'm cutting out blue.
No, I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
Okay, fuck.
Five-year-old auntie.
He's got infinite range.
All right, nice.
Okay, now I can be fast again.
I just realized I haven't been fast for a long time.
Things were... Oh my god, I got a little dizzy.
There's too many things going on.
You what?
Mortar.
Okay, I need you... I need you to... Where's Camo?
Okay, I need you to be able to do all of this, little monkey.
I... I need you...
I need you to do something.
I need all my monkeys to do something.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
I believe in my monkeys.
And then...
Bigger bombs.
Surely, bigger bombs means a...
Means bigger hits.
Surely.
All right.
There you go.
You have cannons now.
All right.
No, I'm just so...
I'm just so confused.
I...
I'm just...
Incredibly confused, guys.
I...
All right.
Things are fine, though.
Oh!
I was like...
Why...
Why he no pop?
Okay, I need you to be able to do that.
Okay, I need you to be able to see that, too.
Okay.
Frag bombs.
There you go.
You go do your thing.
And then...
I'm level 10!
More snipers with night vision?
All right, let me...
I'm unlocking so many things, but like, I'm too...
I'm too overwhelmed to do more stuff.
Night vision.
Okay.
There we go.
That should be fine.
And then...
You get camo, too.
And...
You know what?
I should be upgrading you.
I don't know why I was not doing that.
Faster throwing...
I don't know.
That seems like a cool thing to upgrade.
These...
Take loads, and when they do, they...
What?
Wait.
Oh my god, thank god.
Okay, they broke.
Okay, I got scared.
I...
I got really scared.
You guys just...
Oh, I did it!
Not even close!
Die!
Cyclone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There's been this person outside my house these past few days making crow sounds and then leaving.
I feel awkward to tell you this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And Todd, thank you for the super chat.
I'm cutting up, dude.
Oh my god.
This was incredibly overwhelming.
Wait.
If I do free play, do I get more?
Do I get more...
More out of it?
What do I get out of it?
For free play.
I should start upgrading my stuff.
That was so easy, guys.
I wonder when things get hard.
Make a little effect.
Glue through.
Soaks through all that.
It's just...
Oh, you actually get less experience.
More XP for...
Oh, it's not worth it?
Okay, goodbye monkeys.
How do I leave?
Goodbye monkeys.
Alright.
Not now.
I don't need to back it up.
Wait, can I unlock other monkeys?
Oh, I have to...
It's like quest.
Okay, so all I can have is Quincy.
Help Quincy with a little help.
What do I get out of it?
Wait, what do I get if I help Quincy?
He's an archer with amazing accuracy.
Alright.
Okay.
Doesn't seem all too bad if it's just Quincy.
Right?
Alright.
Yeah.
Doesn't seem all too bad.
I'm just gonna use Quincy.
Nothing get past Quincy's bow.
Hawkeye wishes he was him.
Looks like there are too many.
Use Quincy's rapid shot.
Oh, I just...
Oh, I do have it again.
Yay!
Nice.
Doesn't seem all too bad.
Nothing gets past Quincy.
Every third that lemon popped lead balloons.
Oh shit.
He's so strong now.
He's uneven.
I think he's better than Hawkeye.
Wait.
Quincy.
You...
You left him.
Quincy, what the fuck?
How did you fuck up?
How did you...
Quincy, what the fuck?
How did you fuck up?
Quincy!
Shoot him!
He can't do everything.
What's the point if he can't do everything himself?
What's the point?
He's throwing.
Don't spam your...
If they gave me abilities, I might as well be allowed to spam them.
On cooldown.
Wait, these abilities are so fast.
Oh, I think it's because it's the game itself spam.
Oh, it's because I finished the round.
Oh, it's because I've auto-started.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, not nice.
This might be where Quincy dies.
Guys, why didn't you tell me to stop spamming?
Why?
Guys.
Guys, why didn't you stop me?
Oh, I can use other monkeys!
Oh, shit!
Um...
Okay.
Here we go.
Ice monkey.
Ice monkey, do your thing!
Oh, shit.
Quincy can't do all of this himself!
Come on!
Okay, he's maxed out.
Uh...
Go, ice monkey, go!
Oh, shit!
I sold him!
Sorry, ice monkey!
Do your thing again!
Oh, fuck!
Um...
Um, sniper!
Uh...
Cannon!
Ability!
Oh, come on!
Oh, my God!
It is...
Oh, don't.
Ability!
It's fine.
Nothing to worry about.
We made it.
We made it, guys.
We...
We made it!
Nothing to worry about.
We still have ability!
Yeah.
Jesus Christ, this is a little too close.
It's a little too close for comfort, guys.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Yay!
We did it!
This is not Quincy's fault.
What?
And it's...
You think it's my fault?
Wait till she finds out that was just a baby.
They're...
Wait, they get bigger?
AKB, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Prom, Amaro, thank you for the super chat.
Alright, nice.
I did it.
It's pretty easy.
Alright, nice.
I got power, energizing, and super monkey storm.
What do I do with those?
Okay.
Wait, is there more stuff for Quincy?
No, that's like tutorial.
What's this?
Oh, I get to unlock.
Oh, are these skins?
Why would I use my money on skins?
I could use it on more monkeys.
Oh!
Okay, so I can do more there.
Monkey money can be spent on new heroes.
Are permanent upgrades?
Is permanent upgrades these?
Are these the permanent upgrades?
Skins equals win, of course.
God, Doki.
It's like you don't know how to play...
How to play mobile games.
Monkey knowledge?
Where's monkey knowledge?
Is she monkey knowledge because she has glasses?
Oh, not unlocked yet.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, this one.
I see it.
Oh!
What the fuck?
What?
What about...
Oh, fuck.
Guys, bloons is a lot more complicated than I thought.
I hate bloons.
Medium?
Blue is more normal.
Yeah.
Beating round 60.
A war to a silver.
Melon.
$75.
Yeah.
Let's just keep going on easy, guys.
Let's...
Let's stay here a little longer.
Guys.
Let's stay here.
Let's stay here a little longer.
Enjoy our time.
In monkey meadows.
Guys, it's $75.
$75 is $75, okay?
I'm just enjoying my time.
In...
In monkey meadows.
Okay.
Alright.
Just trying to have a good time.
Oh.
Oh, that's fast.
That's fast.
Okay.
Alright.
A little slow and steady.
Slow and steady wins the race.
Slow and steady.
Alright.
It's fine.
Okay.
We just need to save up for...
Ice monkey.
The moment we have ice monkey, things will get easier.
Oh, don't level up the hero?
Oops.
Alright.
There we go.
Clap!
Clap for me!
I trust him.
Get yourself a girl that trust...
That trust you unconditionally like...
Ice monkey trust...
Like how I trust ice monkey.
Go clap!
Do your job!
I believe in you!
You're doing great, sweetie!
I'm gonna get this just in case.
I don't...
I'm gonna get this.
I'm worried about the meadow man.
I'm afraid of the meadow man.
Alright.
Stickier glue?
Or...
You know what?
I feel like it should be both.
This one, right?
It seems better.
Okay.
We need more ice monkey.
Ice monkey seems really strong.
Okay.
Alright.
Ice monkey!
You know what?
Fuck it.
I need almost close to end up more ice monkey.
Do your thing!
Keep clapping!
I'm almost close to more ice monkey!
Ariel.
What's permafrost?
Plutus must slowly even when...
Is this even a worthy upgrade?
Oh, it is.
Alright.
We'll do that and...
We'll do permafrost and enhance freeze.
Two ice monkey is better than one ice monkey.
You know...
That's what I'm saying!
Nice.
Okay.
We'll get sticky or glue.
We like it when things get sticky!
Ice monkey.
You know what?
I think I can make an entire army of just ice monkey.
Oh, wait.
Yay!
My chicken soup!
Keep doing your thing.
Keep looking cool!
More ice monkey!
Come on!
Don't worry.
You know what this needs?
More ice monkey.
Alright.
We gotta make him look cooler.
And then...
Here.
And...
We'll have larger freeze area.
Yay!
Level 12!
Alright.
Larger radius.
There we go.
That's what we need.
More ice...
The world needs more ice monkey.
Alright.
Yes.
Surely that's not gonna backfire, right?
Hahaha!
Surely...
That's not gonna fuck me over, right, guys?
The world just needed more ice monkey.
I mean, it's working!
I think.
You know what we need?
More ice monkey!
Hahaha!
That's right!
Keep doing your thing!
I gotta upgrade it.
There you go.
Yes, but you would not listen anyway!
I think you don't!
Oops!
Ah!
Ice monkey!
I'm just saying.
I think...
More ice monkey is always the plan.
Everybody loves ice monkey!
Yay!
Level 13!
Monkey money!
Alright.
See?
It's all working out!
They're freezing everything!
It's all ice!
Look at that!
Look at him go!
Okay, I need to do this.
Hahaha!
I may or may not be a little worried right now.
But it's okay.
I'll never doubt you, ice monkey.
Uh...
Don't sleep.
I'll never doubt you.
My little monkeys.
Alright.
I just gotta save.
Hope you're ready for more.
It's okay.
My ice monkey sees through all.
My ice monkey can see through everything.
Okay.
We need to shoot smaller ice bombs.
That slows blooms and frees water.
Okay.
We...
There you go!
Keep using more!
Alright.
You know what?
I'll give you...
I'll give you more sticky.
I think I can put more...
Wait.
Actually, I should save up.
I should actually...
Alright.
You're right.
I need...
Wait.
Did I do it?
Yay!
Oh shit!
Don't worry.
I got...
I got the plan.
Don't worry!
I got the plan!
Dude!
Don't worry!
He's here!
They're all here!
All my monkeys know what they're doing!
Alright.
Nice.
Let's upgrade.
Oh my god!
Super...
Super brittle!
Do I have enough?
Okay.
Wait.
Enough here.
And then...
We'll...
Upgrade this guy.
Oh, we should upgrade him.
But he doesn't matter as much.
Let it go.
They think it can get past my army of ice monkeys.
Foolish bloons!
So foolish!
Welcome to Canada!
Oh shit.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
I...
I got a little word.
Nice.
I wonder what Stokey's favorite monkey is.
He can't...
Guys, I think she likes Ice Monkey.
I'm just saying!
Ice Monkey's pretty strong!
He's pretty fucking strong.
Not gonna lie.
Wait.
He only has one?
Which is better?
Quincy or...
Gwendolyn?
Quincy actually...
Wait.
Which is better?
Quincy or Gwendolyn?
Should we tell her?
Gwen?
Alright, let's check her out.
Let's check out what she does.
Uh, Duck!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Ice Monkey was the lunar snow of our times.
Clapping while no one else could.
He's just a chill guy.
Fire can solve any problems.
Gwen can take out leads with ease.
As she...
Levels...
Up...
She buffs...
Taliter towers.
Especially the ones with fire attacks.
Okay.
What'd she do?
Alright, do your thing, Gwen.
Boom.
What the fuck?
She just let two through.
Hello?
Gwen?
Shoot them!
What?
Gwen!
She just let two through!
They put her there!
Like, what am I supposed to do?
Okay.
It's not my fault if they put her there by themselves!
Wait, what?
Oh, here.
Okay.
Stupid fucking...
Gwen...
I fucking...
Okay.
Alright, Gwendolyn.
I...
Goodbye.
How did I lose in the tutorial on Gwendolyn?
Like...
Alright.
That's fine.
Gwen's height makes her a good hero for saving up...
Alright.
Now I know.
This is fine.
I put it down.
Surely...
Surely I'll be fine now.
Surely.
Alright.
I was set up to fail.
There's a lot about to come up.
Wait till they're all on screen and use the Firestorm ability to put them down.
Okay.
I think that's all of them, right?
I can't...
I'm just set up to fail.
I'm...
I'm just set up!
I'm just...
Okay.
Alright.
Restart.
Clearly.
Okay.
I figured it out.
Guys.
Alright.
This is fine.
I know what to do now.
I know what to do.
It's just Gwen things.
Balloons.
Okay.
Those balloons will never be popped.
I guess.
I did!
I thought that was all of them!
I got a little quirky, okay?
I thought that was all of them.
The Crusher button?
What's the Crusher button?
What's that?
What?
There's no Crusher button here.
Alright.
Pass through.
Oh, on the map?
There's something on...
Oh!
Too late.
I crushed...
Alright.
It's gone.
Whoops.
Does it go back up?
Guys, when does it...
Okay, it goes back up.
Okay, guys.
It's okay.
I figured it out.
Alright.
It's okay, guys.
I learned my lesson.
Alright.
Is that all of them?
It's gone.
Okay.
Nice.
I got it.
Alright.
Add some towers and complete the rest of the rounds.
Oh, shit.
Um...
Uh...
I learned.
It's okay.
I...
I'm...
I'm gonna play the game now.
I'm gonna play...
I just...
It's okay.
I figured it out.
But you can't earn any more.
Oh.
Ice monkey.
Ice monkey will never fail me.
Ice.
I believe... I believe in the power of ice.
Don't worry.
Oh no!
I believe... I believe in the power of ice.
Don't worry.
Ice monkey.
Ice monkey's time to shine.
Chad, are we cooked?
How can we be cooked?
We have ice monkey.
Alright, I'm gonna go get my chicken soup.
Ice monkey will cover for me.
I did it!
Yay!
Oh, ninja monkey.
I got my chicken soup, guys.
Look at that!
Ice monkey's doing it!
How could he fail?
How can he fail?
Exactly!
Look at him go!
Don't worry.
My ice monkey can see through camo.
I think.
I might have forgot what I upgraded.
But I think he can... I think it's possible.
Go ice monkey!
Go!
I believe.
Look at him!
Look at him clap!
Keep clapping!
If you believe hard enough, ice monkey can get us through the finish line.
Oh, only two monkeys can see camo.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Ice monkey reigns supreme.
As long as they keep clapping, nothing can kill me.
My chicken soup!
Hmm.
You see, the problem is...
Oh, I was on slow this entire time.
Whoops.
That was like, wow.
Ice monkey is so strong.
I mean, we're almost halfway.
Don't...
I love tropicos.
Thank you for the 50 gifted shows.
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
See, look at that!
My two monkeys doing it!
They saw through the camo!
Famous last words?
It's so...
It's so doable!
You got the...
Yeah!
The surviving blues are doing nothing!
They can't even get past my bridge of ice!
Firebomb!
Firebomb that shit!
Gwen!
Does she know?
Oh my god!
Super monkey!
I got Superman on my side!
Oh my god!
Goodbye!
Oh shit!
Guys...
616?!
Okay guys...
I think...
I think Ice Monkey was not it.
Who would've thought...
Okay, what do we do?
Two Ice Monkeys...
And then we'll do...
This guy...
Right here...
And then...
We'll upgrade...
Range...
And then...
Super Range...
And then we'll put Sniper Monkey...
And then...
Plane Monkey...
Another Ice Monkey...
Cause they never fail me!
Yeah...
Ice Monkey will never fail me!
Alright...
And then I'll start...
Upgrading other stuff...
And then...
Alright...
There we go...
I think...
I think we're five...
And then another Ice Monkey...
There we go...
Now we have the strat guys...
Now...
Now we have the strat...
There we go...
I think this is it...
I think this is the strat guys...
This is...
This is the right...
This is the real strat...
You know what you're right...
I should add one more Ice Monkey...
For the ride...
Let's just...
Add one more...
Just to be sure...
Hmm...
It's okay...
You know what...
You're right...
I'll add two more...
That was our main issue...
We needed two more Ice Monkeys...
And then...
Here we go...
There we go...
It's perfect now...
Now this is perfect...
Honestly...
I think...
I think I got it...
I figured it out...
I definitely figured it out guys...
This is...
This is what we forgot to do...
I think...
I think this is the real strat...
How could I mess this up?
How could I possibly...
Mess this up now?
Hahaha...
The true meta...
It will always work...
Until it doesn't...
Alright...
As soon as the big guy comes over...
I'll know...
I'll know what I did wrong...
Hahaha...
She didn't know...
It's okay...
I leveled up!
I want...
Wizard Monkey...
Here we go...
Watch this...
Alright...
And that freeze...
See?
There you go!
I figured it out!
I told you...
That's what I was missing all along...
I knew it!
I knew it guys!
I was missing two more Ice Monkeys!
That was...
What I needed!
I just needed two more!
Now it's over!
I just needed to use my abilities!
There you go!
I'm gonna save the freeze one for later...
I feel like...
The freeze one matters more later on in the line...
Alright...
Firebomb!
The bloons have extra armor...
Making them even tougher to pop!
Nothing is too tough for my Ice Monkeys!
Alright...
There we go!
Look at them go!
Look at them!
They're denying everything!
I've always believed in you!
Firebomb!
They can't even get past this part!
That's how good they are!
Look at them go!
How am I cooked?
I'm literally...
It's so easy right now!
I put Firebomb in here!
They can't do shit!
Look!
I got 50 Monkey Money!
Alright...
I'll use the Ice thing later!
Firebomb!
Look at that!
I'm ready for another Firebomb!
Did someone say Firebomb?!
Firebomb!
That's right!
Oh...
Fire Firebomb!
Um.
There we go.
I got more in me.
I got more fire bombs in me!
Oh shit.
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
That was a little scary, but it's fine.
It's fine.
It got a little scary there.
Oh shit.
Alright, there we go, its okay.
Look at that.
I got rid of them.
I got more fire bombs in me.
OH MY GOD.
Okay, okay.
I didn't expect a second balloon to hit, but it's okay.
Oh my god.
Firebomb!
There you go.
I have more abilities.
Changing target can sometimes help.
Wait, I can do that?
I can do that?
How the fuck do I change target?
Firebomb.
Oh no.
It's fine.
They're all broken.
Oh.
It's fine.
I still have HP.
Wait, Tab?
What?
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
What?
Oh no.
No!
I'm so close.
I know what I did wrong.
I know exactly what I did wrong.
I need the
plane though.
The plane actually helped.
Wait.
Actually, yeah.
The plane did shit.
Okay.
All right.
This is perfect.
My perfect build.
My...
There we go.
And then...
We'll put glue boy here just in case.
You just do whatever you do, glue boy.
Do your thing, glue boy.
Do your thing.
This is fine.
We figured it out.
Firebomb.
Oh, so like...
How do I move this?
How do I move it though?
Oh, I got Druid Alchemist.
Wait, how do I move the thing?
Oh.
Wait.
I don't understand.
Sorry.
How safe it is.
Thank you.
Oh, is it this?
Oh.
I'll put it here.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Five bombs right...
Or maybe I'll put...
I like this target right here.
I feel like this part actually was good.
Don't worry.
He knows what's up.
Put it in the crossroads?
Like here?
Oh, I see.
Here.
Oh, that's smart actually.
Firebomb!
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's freeze everything.
Just for the fun of it.
Watch this.
Fire...
Firebomb!
Look at him go.
I can do more.
You know what?
This is easier now.
I literally have...
So many ice monkeys for this.
Firebomb!
Alright.
I'm keeping this for the Morba.
Or Moba.
Alright.
This is it.
I believe.
There you go.
Okay.
He should be dead here.
Yes.
Nice.
Okay.
How...
Guys.
Um...
I don't understand.
Is Ice Monkey not a viable strat?
I don't...
I don't understand.
What could I be doing wrong?
I don't...
What could I possibly be doing wrong?
Ah, I guess I'll never...
It's okay.
I have Ice Monkey.
I don't understand what I could be doing wrong.
Wait.
I think I might lose this already.
Okay.
I realized I shouldn't put Ice Monkey first.
Let me put...
Okay.
Let me put DPS in.
And then...
We know...
Doki.
Sorry.
That was my bad.
I should not have put Ice Monkey first.
I didn't realize I don't have enough money.
Okay.
There we go.
Now this should be easier now.
Now it should be a little easier.
We'll do...
Improve...
Actually, I want to improve range.
The problem is that you need more Ice.
You're right.
I have enough DPS now.
This should be easier.
I have enough DPS.
Okay.
I just need like 500 dollars so I could put five Ice Monkey in here.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Your hero is here.
Ice Monkey!
Alright.
I'm gonna save up more for Hot Range.
What's this?
Is this Hot Range?
Okay.
Alright.
Hot Range.
Does he have enough now?
Oh, he does.
Okay.
And then I gotta save up for more Ice Monkey.
Don't worry.
I'm almost there.
The hero is coming in.
Don't worry.
Just need a couple of more dollars.
The hero is here.
Ice Monkey!
That's right, everybody.
Cheer for Ice Monkey!
Woo!
Ice Monkey!
Okay.
I feel like...
Definitely need longer range and more tacks.
And then upgrade...
Uh...
We'll do this.
Alright.
And then...
Ice Monkey!
Oh!
Our hero!
The hero!
The hero we all deserve!
Ice monkey!
Okay, I feel like I should definitely add another one here.
Alright.
A people's monkey!
Oh, it can... Oh, wait, really?
I did not know that.
Whoops.
It's fine.
We have...
We'll save up for helicopter monkey.
I haven't done anything with helicopter monkey before.
Alright, let's see.
You know what?
Let's do refreeze.
And then cold snap.
There we go.
Alright, I should save up for this.
I keep forgetting to save up for it.
We need helicopter monkey!
Get in here!
Do it!
Okay, guys, which is a good upgrade for helicopter monkey?
Monkey.
Penguin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Quad?
Alright.
Okay, I need Quad and... Quad and what?
What's my second upgrade?
Top path?
Top two?
Alright.
I believe.
While we're waiting, let's save up for the actual, like, you know... Our guy right here.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, I control him?
Oh, I didn't realize.
I control the helicopter?
Wait, how do I not control you?
Do your own thing!
I... Do your own thing!
I don't... Oh, it auto moves.
Okay, okay.
I have to control them.
For now.
Okay.
Okay, that's good to know.
I was like... I was like, I don't want to be in charge of you!
You're your own person!
Alright.
That's fine.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
Shoot him!
Oh, no.
Okay.
That's fine.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
No, I almost spent my... I almost bought that!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Now I don't have to worry.
Alright.
Here we go.
Things are fine now.
Everything is okay.
Now I can spend more money on what truly matters in life.
And then... Let's do it here.
Alright.
Uh... Yes.
Be able to shoot that.
Go, sniper monkey!
Let's go!
You know what this world needs?
More eyes.
Yes.
More eyes!
Yay, level up!
I got a new hero!
Wait, did I finish it?
Oh, wait.
No.
There's still 60.
Alright.
I was like, yippee!
I did it!
60 more to go.
Okay.
Go clap.
Keep clapping.
Okay.
Nice.
I can keep upgrading.
Uh... Upgrade.
Bless me.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck!
I... That's awkward.
It's fine.
I did a little too early, but that's okay.
It still worked.
It still worked, guys.
I might have done it a little early, but it's still okay.
Okay.
Nice.
More ice.
Freeze.
Ice.
Ice, baby.
Alright.
And then... Almost have enough for more.
Nice.
Keep clapping!
Clap!
Clap my monkeys!
Yes!
I love my clapping monkeys.
Alright.
He big boy now.
Oh, my God!
You're big boy!
28,000?
Jesus Christ!
I do not have that money.
I should upgrade- I should really upgrade my other monkeys, I- Alright, 2,000.
Okay, we'll do with you first.
Alright.
We'll do with both of you first.
I should really- Okay, nice.
Alright.
Gotta get those- Gotta get those firemouth.
2,200?
That's fine.
I just need to get there.
Alright, my ice monkeys are all fully leveled up.
I guess I can upgrade my other stuff now.
Um, I guess they matter too.
Oh, what's this?
Support monkeys.
And to gain money, spend on more stuff.
Monkey village?
Use range by- Holds a trusty nail gun that Pop can upgrade to create its own nail shooting- What do I get?
Banana farm?
What do I do with banana farm?
Monkey farm time.
Cash by tapping.
Don't wait too long to boil it.
How do I tap the banana?
Where is the banana?
Where is it?
Where the fuck is the banana?
Oh, there it is.
Oh!
Oh, shit!
I got distracted!
I was trying to figure out how to tap the banana!
Okay, this is illegal.
I was trying to tap the banana there.
Okay.
Let's see.
I just wanted to tap the banana!
Oh, wait!
Oh, my monkeys are- Oh!
They tap it for me!
Wait, I think I got the strat.
What is that?
Or is it my ha- Oh, it's me.
I'm just tapping it myself.
Oh, haha, okay.
It's okay.
Everything is okay.
Everything is okay right now.
Oh, my god.
Everything is so fast right now, too.
Okay.
Nice.
Should be able to afford that.
What next?
I'm so strong!
I'm so strong now.
Look at him go!
Look at me go!
I don't even have to worry about anything!
Alright, what do I get next?
Spike Factory?
There's a- Oh, I should get that.
Put it here.
There we go.
More farm- Set to strong- More farms be there!
Why do I do this?
Increase production.
Easy collect.
Oh, I'll do- More- More bananas.
More bananas.
More farms.
Base.
It is so easy.
This is actually such an easy game.
I figured out the meta.
I just need three ice monkeys, and a helicopter.
What the fuck is that?
Oops, sorry.
I used- It's fine.
Don't have to worry about it.
I still won.
Yay!
What did I get?
Nice.
I got money.
Oh, hey!
He's new!
Who's he?
I've never seen him before!
Wrong placement.
I don't know!
My chat has been very helpful and very nice to me.
They like the Ice Monkey meta.
I created a new meta.
What's this?
Where's the- Where's the boss fight?
I think I can deal with the boss fight.
What?
Daily challenge?
Is this the boss fight?
Are these the boss fight?
Bottom path is ice only.
Click the two monkeys.
Him?
You're not ready?
Don't tell me what to do!
I'm always ready!
I'm ready!
I know when I'm ready!
Whoa!
Guys, I might not be ready.
Wait, this guy's a little freaky!
Boss appears in 39 rounds, and you know what I- Oh, shit.
Wait, I already fucked up.
Okay.
Alright, there we go.
Now, it should be okay.
Uh.
GG.
I'm sorry.
It was like my first instinct to go- To do Ice Monkey.
It was just like a first instinct thing.
Okay.
You're not SpongeBob.
You aren't ready.
Penguin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Damn.
That's fine.
Now I'm ready.
Now I'm actually ready.
Now...
I should be okay.
Damn.
Alright, and then I should save up for this.
Should be fine.
No, I'm not cooked already.
I just started.
How could I fuck up already?
I literally...
Just started with me rounds...
How am I supposed to afford it?
It's five!
It's a thousand dollars!
I... I'm broke!
Now I just wait for my trump card.
I just got... I'm patient.
Now I just gotta wait for Ice Monkey.
Ice Monkey!
Hehehehe.
There you go.
Now it's winnable.
Now it's winnable, guys.
Alright.
The hero has arrived.
The people's hero.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Now save up for the farm.
It can't be that bad.
He won't lose.
No, I won't!
He's the people's hero!
He's a... he's a hero!
How could I lose with a hero by my side?
Look!
I'm already halfway to a farm!
Look at that!
Okay, this is a little bad.
Yo, I'll put this here just in case.
I... I don't know.
I feel a little...
I feel a little bad here.
Okay.
Now I should have enough.
Alright.
Can you skill?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, shit.
I did that out of panic.
Because...
That was out of panic, guys.
Because I got a little worried.
I got a little worried there.
But it's okay.
I almost have a farm.
And then I can have multiple...
uh...
See?
Look, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Now I have...
Now I have my farm.
It's okay.
And then I can have multiple ice monkeys.
Alright, nice.
See?
Look.
And then I can have multiple ice monkeys.
It's okay.
See?
Things are gonna be...
Okay.
Thanks will be okay.
Okay, and then all I need is... oh my god, all I need is more here.
Uh, things... things will be... okay.
Alright.
I just realized we have nothing that can kill that.
Okay, things...
It's okay, I have my farm.
It's fine.
We have sniper monkey.
We have sniper monkey, guys.
There we go.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
Look, we have stronger ice monkey now.
Look at that.
Strong ice monkey, look at that.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Calm down.
Alright.
Look at them go.
Look at them.
Whoa, look at them go.
See?
Look at them go.
Oh, the boss appears in 10 rounds.
This is getting a little worse.
But it's okay.
Just keep believing.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
It's okay.
It's all right.
Firebomb.
It's okay.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
Oh, the fear.
I just need a helicopter.
The things will be okay.
The moment I get a helicopter, things will be okay.
Guys, things will be okay.
Helicopter.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Helicopter.
Firebomb.
There we go.
$500.
$500 is fast.
We get $500.
Okay, there we go.
See, nothing to worry about.
Nothing to worry about.
Why were you all so scared?
I wasn't scared.
I wasn't scared at all.
I was not scared at all.
I knew what I was doing.
I knew exactly what I was doing.
Alright, I need... what was it?
The tactic.
Okay, a thousand dollars.
We can afford that.
Okay, here we go.
There we go!
What do I not know?
What do I... what do I... what could I possibly not know?
What could it be?
Alright.
Everything seems okay so far.
Nothing much to worry about.
Oh!
Oh, what is that?
Uh...
What is that?
What am I looking at?
What...
What can I...
What am I looking at?
What do you mean?
Where's Super Monkey?
I thought...
Oh, it's 2,500.
Oh, wait.
Super Monkey, it is your time to shine.
It is your time.
Guys, what do I get for Super Monkey?
What does he need?
Guys, what does he need?
It's okay.
I have a play.
Go in there!
Do your thing!
Oh my God, he needs rage, but he's so weak.
He needs rage, but he's so weak.
Oh my God, why is your XP so low?
Game over?!
Where did...
Where was he going?!
Alright.
Guys, I might not be ready for boss fight.
Let's go back to baby level.
We'll go back to...
The comfort of Monkey Meadows.
Wait, where's my ice monkey?
What?
How do you win without...
Ice Monkey?
How do you do that?
There's...
You can win without Ice Monkey?
That's a thing?
Ice Monkey is military too!
He...
He enlisted!
He also enlisted!
Okay, how the fuck...
Okay, that's just like...
Like...
How?
How the fuck do I...
What?
I guess faster firing...
Even then, I can't even fucking afford it.
Oh, I need to attack speed first?
Whoops.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
Okay, it's fine.
Now I know.
Now I can upgrade you.
All right.
There we go.
And then I'll save up for the hero.
Wait, it's a lot easier now.
Blunarism later.
And then thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It can't get that bad now.
I just gotta wait.
I'm patient enough.
I can wait.
I miss Ice Monkey.
Wait, maybe...
Maybe I do.
I can't wait.
Sorry, guys.
Apparently, I can't actually wait.
Now, now I can wait, guys.
Now I can wait.
I'm patient now.
I swear to God.
I can wait this time.
Oh, my God.
Okay, this is a little...
Okay, no, we're fine.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Things are okay now.
I can wait this time.
Can I need 350?
And then I'll put in...
I'll do another upgrade for that.
I need to get another...
Sniper Monkey to focus on this upgrade.
There you go.
Just in case.
And then...
Uh...
And I'll wait for...
I'll get another Sniper Monkey.
Should be fine.
Nice.
Okay, and then I'll focus on upgrading.
I'll get another...
Okay, I think it's fine, right?
Fire Bomb.
Okay, let's put it here.
Yeah, see?
I'm learning.
I'm learning, guys.
You can't teach me new tricks.
And then I'll do...
Night Goggles.
Look at that!
This is all snipers.
Okay, I should save up for the helicopter, though.
I'm gonna save up for a helicopter.
I can read!
Okay, maybe...
Pass through for...
Hmm...
No, I should save up.
I should save up for a helicopter.
Fire Bomb!
Look at that!
Let me go!
Play on the hardest level!
On the hardest map!
I'm so good, guys.
Pew, pew!
Alright.
Stay here.
Wait.
Fire Bomb!
Okay, that should be enough, right?
Okay, I need 500 now.
Wait, 60 rounds?!
I still have 60 rounds?!
Jesus Christ.
Alright, now I don't have to care about them.
Okay, and then...
Bigger jets.
So you can get the camo.
And...
I should actually save up for the mortar.
And then camo.
And then now I'll save up, guys.
Okay, wait.
After I get this.
Now!
Now I'll save up.
Okay, after I get this, though.
This is important.
Okay, now...
Now I can...
I'll save up.
Alright, Engineer Monkey.
Well, I can't do anything with him, though.
Alright, now I'll save my money.
For real.
Well...
Alright.
I couldn't help it!
There are so many options!
What do I get for him?
Bigger blast.
Which is good, guys.
Faster reload.
Reload?
Alright.
I'll do reload and I'll do bigger blast.
Attack speed.
There's attack speed?
The biggest... this one?
Faster reload?
Bigger blaster.
Increase accuracy.
More ice.
Guys, if I could, my entire area would be ice monkey.
If I could.
Okay, but like, do I have to be accurate or could I just... You know what?
Top is worse path.
Top, bigger blast.
You know what?
Bigger means... means like it'll hit more.
That's how I like to go at it.
Alright, and then we'll... Let's level up this.
Yeah, we don't need accuracy as long as it hits.
We just need things to go kaboom.
Boom.
There you go.
As long as things go kaboom, things will be fine.
Fire bomb.
Alright.
I'm gonna wait for a bouncing bullet next.
I don't think we need... Oh wait, what if we have two helicopters?
Oh my god.
Two helicopters, double the fun.
And then the two helicopters can get to know each other and make babies.
And then we'll have baby helicopters.
Oh, I should not have upgraded that.
I should have tried the bottom path.
Toki?
What?
Then we'll have baby helicopters.
That's how baby helicopters are... That's how drones are born.
And then when the mommy helicopter and the daddy helicopter loves each other very much, we get drones.
Don't eat.
What?
Is that how drones are born?
Insane.
That's how...
That's the miracle of drone birth.
Let's just have more helicopters.
Just have everything.
It's just helicopters.
No, I can't...
I can't...
Okay, we'll redo the...
Okay, this time I will use the correct path.
Alright, there we go.
I keep fucking up.
I keep fucking this up.
Okay, there we go.
This is what I wanted to do.
There we go.
Now...
Now we have a whole family.
Alright.
Wait, doesn't this give me...
Okay.
Cause it...
Oh my god, there it goes!
See?
There's a drone!
I knew it!
When a mommy and daddy helicopter loves each other very much, we get drones!
I fucking knew it!
I knew it existed.
I'm saving up for that.
It's true.
I knew it was real.
You guys laughed.
But I knew it was real.
It's true.
Alright.
I'm saving up for the babies.
This is much more important.
Alright.
There is...
We're almost there.
We're halfway.
We're halfway to the baby.
I can't believe this.
I told you!
That's how we get drones!
They fell in love!
Oh my god.
It happened so fast.
We're so close.
We're so close to the baby.
Fire bomb.
Okay.
I might have used that a little too early.
There we go.
Baby time!
Yay!
Oh my god.
It's happening so fast that like...
They don't even know what's going on.
Anymore.
I have enough for...
For this.
I might as well upgrade that.
Since I have money anyway.
Bro, that ship can't even get over...
Wait.
This is a strat.
Helicopters and ice.
I figured it out.
This is a real strat.
Helicopters and ice.
I figured it out for real this time.
True.
Alright.
But if I had ice...
Then this would have been over like...
20 years ago.
Nice.
Nice car.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe Doki is showing...
A strong birth live on YouTube.
I can't believe she's getting away with it.
Thank you for the super chat, Steven.
Thank you, thank you.
Workshop.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is PSA for how baby drones are made.
Was brought to you by the US Department of Foreign Policy.
Yay.
We can't even get past who, like...
Get past the Gwendolyn right now.
Gwendolyn's just chilling.
Helicopters and ice sounds aggressively Canadian.
Medium.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yay.
I've got green foot.
I'm worried that's the last round.
Okay.
Four helicopters might have been a little overkill.
Boom.
That's right.
What you gonna do now?
Yay.
Easiest paycheck for Gwendolyn.
Gwendolyn won by doing nothing at all.
Nice.
I did it.
What is the harder one?
Apocalypse.
Wait.
What is apocalypse?
Ever increasing.
No breaks at the end.
How far can you get?
I mean, that was literally how I was playing this game.
Oh, wait.
You mean like right now.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Um...
I didn't realize you mean...
Okay, wait.
Actually.
Let me...
Okay.
I mean, that was literally what I was doing right now.
I didn't realize it was...
When they meant now, it was like now, now.
I...
I didn't realize that's what they meant when they said now.
All right.
But I wanted to do...
Range.
There we go.
Okay.
And then...
Sure.
How was I supposed to know it was right now?
Okay.
We can save up, right?
For the...
What was it?
This thing?
Um...
Here we go.
And then we'll save up for the...
Aces?
What the fuck are aces?
I don't even know what...
They have names?
I know what my strat is.
Should I get Gwendolyn now?
I should get Gwendolyn now, actually.
I should get her now, just in case.
And then I'll save up for this.
Oh my god, you're right.
What am I doing?
How could I forget the main boy?
How could I do this to him?
Sorry, I was way over my head with all the helicopter babies.
I will never forget you, Ice Monkey.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, baby.
I'll never forget you.
You were there for me since the very beginning.
Alright, now we save up for...
Uh, let's put it here.
Now we save up for the banana tree.
Fire bomb!
Alright, nice.
I won't forget you.
Shh.
Don't let them...
Don't let them tell lies, baby.
I know I'll never forget you.
You've been there since the beginning.
They're just telling.
They're just jealous.
They're jealous of what we have.
Alright, there we go.
Okay, and then we do get helicopter.
We save up for helicopter.
Fire bomb!
Alright, and then...
We're so close to the helicopter.
Okay.
Don't...
Don't get tempted to get anything else.
Fire bomb is what it's at.
Fire bomb!
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Um...
Oh, wait.
We have nothing that...
We have...
We have nothing that kills camo.
My bad.
Everything for the helicopter, though.
Guys, it's all the long game.
Long game.
I may have forgot about camo stuff.
Whoops!
Okay.
The moment I get this, I'll focus on camo.
Come on.
You know you wanna pop it.
You know...
There we go.
Alright.
Now I can do what I've always wanted to do.
Now I can save up for the real deal.
Okay.
We need a...
Oh.
Alright.
Uh...
Ooh.
Fire bomb!
Okay.
Let's get sniper in here, too.
Just in case.
Oh.
We might need sniper buddy here.
Uh...
There we go.
Oh.
Why did I do larger radius?
We don't need that.
We don't...
That's fine.
Hey, buddy.
We have fire bomb.
Haha.
That's fine.
We just need more helicopters.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
And then we gotta save up for the actual camo stuff.
What the fuck?
Okay.
We still have only one guy shooting camo, so like, that's not good.
It's okay.
We save up for more helicopters.
Alright.
I keep forgetting.
We're saving up for helicopters.
Haha.
Alright.
It's okay.
Let's try as more helicopters.
It can't go wrong.
More helicopters can never go wrong.
Okay.
We learned that.
Remember.
We just need more helicopters.
We're so close.
Why did we cover it?
Yes.
We're gonna do that too.
Don't worry.
Alright.
Nice.
Fire bomb.
Okay.
We need automatic pursuit.
There you go.
And then this one will be...
This one will be babies.
Don't worry.
I will never forget the baby strat.
Haha.
This.
Don't worry.
A baby strat is here to stay.
Okay.
And then it's monkey time.
And then we upgrade monkey.
Make sure monkey is as strong as it can be.
Alright.
And then we put more monkeys.
Don't worry.
And then we put more.
And then...
And then we do...
This too.
And then we save up more money...
For more monkey.
Okay.
Fire bomb.
And then uh...
And then faster firing.
There you go.
And then...
Monkey.
Fire bomb.
We need a baby.
Give me the baby.
Oh shit.
I almost forgot to collect my money.
Bye.
Come on.
Give me the baby.
We're so close.
The babies.
Okay.
Oh no.
It's okay.
Okay.
Things were... things were not fine.
What did I go wrong?
I don't understand.
What could have possibly gone wrong?
I don't... I don't understand.
What did I do wrong?
I need more... not enough... Oh, you're right.
It's just not enough ice monkey.
Is that it?
You're right, guys.
I don't understand what I did to fuck it up.
I don't... I don't understand.
Alright, you're right.
I need more helicopters.
There you go.
Okay, there you go.
That should work now, right?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Um... Okay, let me slow this down.
Let me... let me slow this down.
So I can figure out what I'm doing wrong.
I...
Like, I'm getting a little...
There's a little too much stuff going on right now.
Okay.
Okay, what's better for...
Um... what's better?
Uh...
More... what's better for... for... for... for... for... for super monkey?
Bottom?
Okay.
Bottom.
Alright, it's fine.
I can't... I can't... I just realized... I have nothing for camo.
It's fine.
Alright, now that I know, I'm leaving.
Now that I know, I leave.
Alright, nice.
Alright, hard road.
Hey, we're getting better!
Alright, remember to not start off with... I need to remember to not start off with Ice Monkey.
Despite how much I want to start off with Ice Monkey.
I... I need to remember, do not start off with Ice Monkey.
You're right, I just didn't have enough Ice Monkey.
You're right.
But it's all gonna change here.
Let me upgrade this part.
It's all gonna change here.
What could go wrong?
Ice Monkey, go clap!
Come on, give me my Ice Monkey.
Alright.
Come on, we're almost there.
Alright, there you go.
I always knew this was the right idea.
I don't know which pathway is better though, guys.
Which... what do we do for the pathway for Ice Monkey?
Oh, this is bad.
Do we need a top... I don't know.
I've been, like, experimenting.
Top path is better?
These two?
Okay.
And then we'll save for Gwen.
Alright.
It's gonna take a while to save though.
Okay.
Or I could get Ice Monkey again.
Ooh, I could get Ice Monkey again though.
Ah.
It's just so...
Guys, you don't understand.
It's just so tempting.
It's like, she's like, right there.
It's like, right there.
Like, can you really blame me?
Ha ha ha ha.
It's...
Can you really blame me?
She's like, right there.
Alright.
Upgrades.
Okay.
Alright.
Now.
Now I upgrade.
For real.
Okay.
I should grab camo stuff though.
Uh.
Okay.
I save.
I save for a tree.
For money.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This is bad.
Sniper Monkey time.
When things get bad, it's sniping time.
Okay.
Now I get Night Vision.
And now I get Fast Firing.
Don't worry.
When things get bad, we snipe.
We start sniping.
We're almost there.
Alright.
Oh, I got Night Monkey knowledge.
I'm smarter now.
Yay!
Wait.
Maybe I do larger raid.
Uh.
Actually.
Enhance Freeze.
Always upgrade my boy.
Sniper Monkey.
Oh shit.
Fire bomb should be here.
Fire bomb!
Go do your fire bomb things!
Oh shit!
Whoops.
Oh.
Wait.
Guys.
I should really start saving my money.
Oops.
Oh, I said as I upgrade.
I should really start saving my money.
Okay.
Now I'll start saving my money.
Alright.
This time.
For real.
And then I'll get the tree.
Fire bomb!
Whoops.
Too early.
Will I ever learn my lesson?
Let's fire it out.
Fire bomb!
Okay.
We're so close.
I need to slow things down.
I can't.
This is a little too rough for me right now.
Things gotta slow down a little bit.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Guys.
We have to slow things down.
Or I'm gonna be so overwhelmed.
I...
I need it.
Fire bomb!
Things are a little too much for my brain right now.
Oh.
Alright.
We're almost there.
We almost have the helicopter.
We don't need cannons, guys.
All we need is a helicopter.
And Gwen.
And ice monkey.
Okay.
I'm almost there.
Helicopter.
There we go.
Oh.
Things are not looking so good right now.
But it's okay.
That's what the helicopter's for.
That's okay.
It's okay, guys.
We're fine.
We have the helicopter here.
We're so healthy.
That's what it is.
We're almost there.
The helicopter's here to save the day, guys.
Okay.
We need 540 and then we're fine.
There you go.
Okay.
Nice.
This is bad.
We only have one guy that can see through camo.
This is okay.
It's okay.
He's doing it.
We have to slow it down a little.
You don't understand.
My brain was starting to hurt.
We have to...
Okay.
We can move it a little bit fast.
Now we slow it down.
So I know what to do after.
All right.
Okay.
Now we can afford...
What do we afford next?
Okay.
Now we can upgrade the banana.
My poor little brain was not going to be okay.
And then helicopter.
And then we need faster darts.
So he can see...
Okay.
We need to upgrade this so he can start seeing camo.
Oh my god.
Please.
I can't upgrade anything yet.
Go bottom banana.
Okay.
But like...
He starts...
He needs to see the stuff right now.
All right.
This one?
But then it does halfway.
Banana salvage?
Ooh.
Banana salvage.
Banana marketplace.
Ooh.
All right.
Okay.
Now I don't have to collect.
All right.
And now...
Now I can upgrade to my content.
Okay.
Hold snap.
All right.
Oh.
I realized I upgraded the wrong camo.
Whoops.
It's okay.
That's what the second...
The second helicopter is for, guys.
That's what the second helicopter is for.
Oh my god.
My monkey was never upgraded.
Okay.
I'll do middle.
Whoops.
That was my bad.
I didn't realize I never upgraded my other monkeys.
No.
We're not cooked, guys.
Things will be okay.
I have enough.
Okay.
Now I can go a little faster.
My brain is okay now.
Now I can go.
Now it's fine.
We'll get the second helicopter and everything will be fine.
And then I'll put fireball in here.
And then we have a second helicopter.
We called in the second buddy.
And then we'll have 650 and then we'll have this guy.
And then fireball.
And then now we're fine.
Now we're fine.
And then we get Superman in here.
All right.
There we go.
And then we save up for Superman.
Or we can do Ice Bucky.
Or we have Ice Bucky here.
I think it's more important.
Honestly, Ice Bucky was like the play.
Yay, Ice Bucky.
I just think it was a play.
Okay, guys.
I think it was the right play to do.
You just don't understand.
Okay, Super Monkey is 2,000.
I think we can afford it.
You always go more Ice.
Exactly!
You know what's up?
Ice is always a play.
Okay, and then we get Super Range.
Super Range and not back.
Okay, and then...
And then we deep freeze.
More freeze.
And I guess we can upgrade our...
No, we save up for more planes.
That was our strat last time and it worked.
Or do I...
Actually...
No, you're right.
Plane is always the answer.
You're so right, guys.
You're so right.
Plane is always the answer.
Okay.
It's okay.
We're almost there.
There we go.
And then...
Faster darts.
Faster.
And then we get a save up for 3,000.
Fireball!
Oh, wait.
I can get more.
All right.
Nice.
And then...
What do I want again?
I already forgot.
I hit some...
Oh, you're right.
More ice.
How could I forget?
Oh, yeah.
I need the Mob's Chove.
I forgot to get that.
That's okay.
We're almost there anyway.
Fireball!
All right.
That's okay.
I'm almost there.
We're almost there.
There we go.
All right.
Now we just focus on upgrading our little guys.
What is this?
Okay.
This...
We'll do this, too.
All right.
And then...
It's ice time.
Yay!
One monkey knowledge point!
Yippee!
Okay.
And then him.
And then...
You there.
That's right.
Oh, wait.
I should get camo.
I almost forgot about camo.
Camo, I think, is pretty important.
It's okay.
I have everything I need in the world.
Okay.
We just have to save it.
Save up for this.
And this should be fine.
All right.
Upgrade.
Faster, bigger stacks, longer reach.
Let's do...
These two.
Let's go.
All right.
Five.
Okay.
I put it too early.
That's okay.
That's five.
Nine thousand.
Okay.
I don't know if I can save up for more babies.
I...
I don't know if I have enough for more babies, guys.
Okay.
Upgrade.
Get you in there.
Oh, I need marketplace.
Oh, you're right.
You're so right.
All right.
We're almost there anyway.
Come on.
Give me my marketplace.
That's right.
Don't worry.
My monkey's strong.
Monkey's so strong.
Oh, my God.
I am generating a lot of money right now.
I need more.
I need more money.
Give me more.
More money.
Monkey demands to be stronger.
True.
Hey, look.
All right.
Let's save up for nine thousand and then make babies.
Or...
Ice monkey.
Ice monkey angi.
Ice monkey is so angry.
Oh, wait.
I can do that.
What is he going to do?
Nothing.
That's right.
I have the marketplace.
I control the market now.
Ice monkey clutch.
Monkey controls marketplace.
Oh, it's in the back now.
That's right.
Oh, my God.
This dart monkey has never been upgraded.
I forgot to upgrade him.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Look at all these darts everywhere.
Oh, it's lagging.
Oh, my God.
There are too many darts.
It actually lagged my game.
The crate.
I put too many.
The game didn't know what to do anymore.
Jesus Christ.
Like, what can I upgrade at this point?
All right.
Nice.
I can do this again.
Yay!
I got another monkey knowledge point!
Okay.
I think it's just...
Yeah.
I just have to wait now.
I'm too strong.
I can't...
Okay.
I can level up this.
I was going to say, I can't level up anything.
All my stuff is too strong.
Yeah.
I can level up this.
All right.
Nice.
Okay.
9,180.
I just need 9,000.
But I can generate more here.
There you go.
I can passively generate income.
Oh my god.
Okay.
How good...
How good my income is now.
I can passively generate income.
And then I should be able to get 9,000 right off the bat.
I'm just farming.
That's all I just gotta do.
I just farm.
And then with that...
I should be able to have the babies so fast.
It's in the bag.
All right.
9,000.
The banana investment of 2025.
Oh my god.
I'm just waiting.
Where are my balloons?
Give me my babies.
I demand the babies.
There you go.
Yay!
Yay.
I got the babies.
Yippee.
All right.
Now I just wait.
I think I upgraded everything I need to upgrade.
That's cheap.
Right?
Yeah.
37, 8,000.
It's just this guy.
Oh, also this guy, I guess.
And then...
Yeah.
Supply.
Drop.
Yeah.
It's just literally this guy.
Just getting him out of the way.
All right.
I just need 8,000.
Just a simple 8,000.
Oh my god.
Look at...
He's...
Oh, I did it?
Oh no.
I just got $200.
Please.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god.
He's robo.
He's robo monkey now.
Burn it all.
What is it?
Do nothing.
You know what?
Let's put another super monkey in here.
Go have fun, super monkey.
Go do your thing.
I have so much money.
It doesn't matter to me.
I just...
I'm just too rich.
All right.
And then we need knock back here.
He's just chilling.
You know what?
More ice monkey.
More ice
monkey.
I demand more ice monkey.
Get him.
Wait, what's that?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
What is that?
Don't worry.
My ice monkey is...
Oh, it's over.
Never mind.
My ice monkey did it.
Free play.
I don't care.
I want more ice monkey in here.
I want to know how far I can get.
Just put it all in here.
Get them all in.
I don't care.
Get in here.
It's ice monkey time.
This is my strat.
This is my ice monkey strat.
In the event, it will work.
Ice monkey time.
They have to get through here first.
They got to get through my ice monkey path.
If they want to do anything.
Her ice kingdom is growing.
That's right.
You got to get past this area first.
All right.
I'll be impressed if it can get through here.
Get through my little...
Little...
Rain of terror of ice.
Oh my god.
My game is like...
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
We're good.
My game is not okay right now.
Crit, crit, crit, crit.
All right.
Now he's the dark knight.
I can make more money.
Let's make more money, guys.
Oh my god.
I can make more money.
All right.
I need 2,000.
Let's make more money so I can put more ice monkeys in here.
Uh...
Her PC's gonna blow up.
No, it's fine.
Wait, what's this?
I can clone myself?
What does he do?
Oh, does he like go somewhere?
Okay.
All right.
Nice.
And then let me get the marketplace.
And then get the central market.
All right.
Nice.
And then we'll put more ice monkeys.
It's fine.
All right.
Nice.
There you go.
And then we'll put more here.
More here.
And then I can't see anything anymore.
But like, I think it's doing okay.
I...
I think things are okay right now.
I can't see anything.
But I think...
I...
I don't know where any of my stuff is anymore.
Um...
But I think everything is okay.
All right.
And then we add...
Another helicopter.
It doesn't hurt.
You have more helicopters.
And then...
Bigger chest.
There you go.
All right.
And then...
And then more ice monkeys.
Put it in here.
And then we'll put you here.
Wait.
Can I not put more?
I can.
Okay.
I can always put more.
Don't worry.
I can't...
Nothing can stop him.
Nothing can stop my army.
All right.
Let's see if we can save up to 21k.
Wait.
My army might be stopped.
No.
That's not possible.
I refuse to believe.
My army of ice will stop them.
This is it.
My army of ice cannot be stopped.
Oh my god.
Wait.
They're...
Wait a minute.
That's a lot of stuff.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm almost there.
I almost got...
The big guns!
Don't worry.
I have the big guns here.
And then we put more helicopter.
Don't worry.
Put more helicopter.
That's fine.
And then we'll do...
Bigger jets.
There you go.
And then firebomb.
I don't think that does anything.
And then we'll add...
More helicopter.
It's fine.
What is this?
Things are okay.
And then...
We'll add more ice monkeys here.
Oh!
Wait.
Things are not fine.
No!
How could this be?
You mean my ice monkeys didn't stop them?
Oh!
So close.
We are almost at 100!
Guys, I might not...
I might have been...
I flew too close to this.
I should have built more ice monkeys.
Yeah!
I did it!
I didn't put more...
The ice kingdom...
Not...
I knew it!
How could I betray my ice monkeys like that?
I can't believe I betrayed them and went with helicopter!
I...
No!
The ice...
The ice melted!
How could I let this happen to my precious ice monkeys?
How?
Okay, but what about the ice monkeys?
Which guys...
Which upgrade...
Oh, wait.
This one.
Super range.
Wizard.
Wait.
What is ice monkey?
Ice monkey is a primary, right?
I...
You take that back!
Ice monkeys are not the worst towers!
That is your...
That is your commander speaking!
Okay.
Let's see.
I believe in...
That's right!
Slap that dragon!
So, who's your favorite monkey champion?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
Let's...
Let's assign that so I can upgrade my ice monkey.
Um...
Middle path on the left start.
Okay.
Um...
Wait.
You mean here?
Whoops!
Ha ha ha ha!
Uh...
I went...
I did the wrong one.
I saw this and then I was like...
Ice!
Okay.
Inferno Rain upgrades.
Free radius slightly increased.
Alright.
Tactical shooters.
Oh wait!
They can pop ice balloons now!
Nice!
Alright.
And then we get...
We should get this.
Alright.
You take that back.
He is your father.
How dare you!
Ha ha ha!
Wait.
What's this?
Create match?
Co-op challenge?
Wait.
Is this a 1v1?
What is this?
Oh!
Wait.
No.
Ha ha ha!
Co-op.
What's co-op?
Create.
Do we get to play together?
Alright guys.
Carry me.
Ha ha ha!
Carry me guys.
I'm Rima Yankee.
Ha ha ha!
Show me how it's done.
Oh, you guys left already?
Cowards.
Oh my god.
All right.
Show me how it's done.
Where's Ice Monkey?
We share cash, right?
Hey, guys.
I got one.
I bought what I wanted.
It's so cute.
Guys, I did what I wanted to do.
Ice Monkey.
I'm here to help out.
The most important.
Yeah, this is the most important monkey.
All right.
Don't worry.
I got everything I wanted to put on.
It's your turn, guys.
Frame one, Ice Monkey.
That's what we needed.
All right.
Frame one.
Don't worry.
We share cash, though.
I know what I'm contributing to this team.
Ice Monkey.
Don't worry.
Wait.
They took off.
Don't worry.
I got you.
There you go.
You don't.
Oh, we don't share cash.
Okay.
You guys are lucky.
I might have almost creeped us by doing that.
Whoa!
We have so much money now!
Wait.
Why do I have so much money?
Don't worry.
My monkey is strong now.
Whoa!
I don't get so much!
What a bitch!
What a cash drop!
Nice!
Someone's already paying the win!
That's crazy!
Guys, we need another one!
We need...
Guys, guys, do another drop!
Whoa!
Let's go!
I know what I'm spending it on.
Let's go.
Let me make my strongest monkey.
Let me make...
Don't enable it.
I'm just making a strong monkey!
Don't worry.
We'll put it on every ice here.
Look at that.
Tier 5 of the most.
You can only have one of each path in play at a time.
Oh my god!
He is a god!
He is an actual god now!
We have the ultimate ice monkey!
Truly.
We have reached peak Nirvana.
What the fuck is going on?
Wait.
Why is he...
There's so many spikes!
Oh my...
Guys, is the game too loud or is it okay?
Is it...
It's a tag.
They saved all the money.
It's a bit loud.
Whoops.
Okay.
Alright.
They're good.
It has been loud!
Why did no one say anything?!
Oh my god!
Why did no one say...
Let him want this!
Wait!
I want...
Why...
It was...
Why did you get all the money?!
So...
Oh, now it's too quiet?
Okay.
I'll set the sound effects down.
Alright.
Here you go.
There you go.
What's going on?
I don't even...
Oh my god!
I'm rich!
You know what that means!
Ultimate Ice Monkey!
Oh my god!
Don't worry.
What do...
Where can I push this?
Where can I...
Don't worry.
There's still a place for him.
Alright.
What have I not upgraded?
Okay.
It's super brittle.
The bottom one.
Okay.
We gotta make one for the bottom now.
Wait.
How do I make it so I can make the bottom one the ultimate monkey?
How...
She's gonna recreate.
We need to get the 5 tier for this.
How do I get it for this guy?
We need all the ultimate monies...
Monkeys.
We need...
We need every ultimate monkey possible.
You can't?
It's bad?
Oh my god.
What's the point?
What's the point if it's bad?
Don't worry.
I'll put you...
Don't worry little guys.
I'll make sure to take all the monkey paths.
I'll make sure it is...
I'll make sure this is just monkeys.
Don't worry little guys.
I'll make sure everything that's empty is just monkeys.
Everything you see here is the land of the monkeys.
I...
There's no more...
Oh wait.
There's one more.
There's one more right here.
Let's go.
There's one.
Let's make sure there's no other path but monkey.
The ice monkey strat is here.
Yippee.
I've taken...
I've taken the whole place.
It's just me.
A lot of fire and ice.
It's like lava...
What do the lavas do?
Is this cosmetic?
What does this do?
Guys, if we lose, it's not my fault.
I'm just gonna say it.
If we lose...
Place ice monkey in the far left above...
Oh my god.
I can't even...
Where?
Is there still a place for my little guys?
Oh my god.
There is.
Right in this tiny little corner.
I knew there would always be a place for you.
I...
Oh, there is!
Nice.
Okay.
There's always a place for you, my little man.
There's always a place for you.
Do not worry.
You'll always have a home here.
You'll always...
Do not worry.
Drown.
Again.
Yippee!
Everybody's so rich.
There's always gonna be a place for all of you.
Alright, nice.
I think we can win this, guys.
Guys.
I think we can win this.
There's no way.
Drown.
Do not be afraid.
Oh my god, there's more!
Nice.
Do not be afraid!
There's always a place for you!
Oh my god, there's some here.
There's always gonna be an area for my eyes.
Honestly, like, I don't...
What are these guys?
A banana farmer?
Do they just give me more money?
What is going on?
What the fuck is going on in my screen right now?
What is happening?
What is going on?
Okay, whatever that flashy thing is, get rid of it.
I don't like it.
I don't like the flashy things.
Alright.
Get rid of it.
No flashy!
Alright.
Are we good?
Do you think we can make it to 100?
Alright, guys.
Goal is 100.
What am I gonna do here?
I feel like I've, like, exhausted all my ice monkeys.
Like, I've done my job.
Alright, wait.
I got an idea.
Okay.
The one helicopter back there.
Ha ha ha ha!
Look at him go.
Oh my god.
It's starting to lag, guys.
No.
What?
There we go.
I'm contributing.
There's no way we could lose this now.
There's no fucking way.
Am I going fast?
Okay, no.
Okay, now I am.
Alright.
Nice!
I leveled up!
Easy.
Level up.
How could we lose?
Look at this build.
How could...
Yeah, that one...
That one heli might have been the game changer.
Look at that.
I have God literally in the middle right here.
Wait.
Oh, am I changing the speed for...
Wait!
Wait, why did you get rid of the lava?
Oh, you're right.
Get rid of the lava so we can put more helicopters.
You're so right, guys.
You guys know how to play the game.
That's right.
Get rid of that.
Just put all heli.
We're just all helicopters now.
This is a helicopter land now.
All helis.
Go in there.
Oh my God.
There's too many.
I placed it incorrectly.
I...
Okay.
Alright.
And then bigger jets.
Oh!
Okay.
Wait.
That's 40,000 XP.
I don't...
I can't afford it yet.
What the fuck is going on?
I don't...
What...
What is going...
What is...
What is going on?
I can't...
I don't know what's going on right now.
There's so many helicopters.
How much XP do I have?
There's just so much.
Money.
Ow.
What is even...
What is happening?
It's just like little insects going back and forth right now.
Money!
What's this?
What am I doing?
Oh my God.
I don't know what...
I don't...
I don't know what's going on.
What are the helicopters?
Oh!
What...
What am I...
Did I kidnap my own monkeys?
What did I...
I don't know what these abilities are!
What did I upgrade?
Deploys a powerful special...
Oh my God!
I get a marine monkey!
I'm deploying the marine...
Get in here!
Oh, I can move my monkeys.
Oh, that's what it does.
Alright.
I don't know where I'm pushing this.
Don't worry, we're at 70 now.
I'm deploying the monkey.
Get in there, private!
Get in there, finish the job!
Select a tower.
Guys...
Guys, my mouse died.
Oh my god.
There's so much stuff going on that my mouse died.
Okay.
Don't worry, my mouse is back here.
There's too much.
I... Is everybody's PC okay?
Is... Is everybody... Yay, level up!
Detecting too much bloons action.
Is everybody...
Is everyone's PC okay?
I can't even... I can't... Oh my god.
Where's my cursor?
I... I don't know where my cursor is!
Oh my... Okay, we're fine.
Welcome to Blue Lake.
But my pit rate is high.
We can go further.
How is there more waves?
Okay.
We can go further, guys.
They can't do anything.
I think they're all dead, guys.
They can't even get past this pathway.
Like, literally...
They can't even get past here.
Guys, we don't need Super Monkey.
Super Monkey is a crutch.
We don't need him.
He doesn't fit in my... In my Ice Monkey land.
He doesn't even fit.
Oh my god.
I don't know where my cursor is anymore.
I...
Where is it?
Where's my... I... Okay, I found it on my other... Where's my cursor?
Where...
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
It's right here.
He's right here, guys.
He's gonna stay in the water for now.
What happens when you cram into... You're about to find out...
I don't even know where anything is.
I can't find out about anything.
My screen is just off.
All fucking Ice Monkeys.
It's okay.
I'm not weak.
We don't need to change our crosshair.
We're almost there.
We're almost at a hundred, guys.
We're all...
We're gonna make it!
Why are we not upgrading our mortar, guys?
Oh, now we are.
I was like...
Guys, you have some baby mortars here.
Fucking upgrade that shit.
You can't afford it.
I know you can.
Or maybe because I...
Maybe I can afford it because I already...
I used up all my money on...
On literally, like...
On my ice, so it wasn't that hard.
But...
Where I'm freezing everything for us.
The cats play Toki.
Someone upgrade their mortars!
There's...
Yay!
Wait, we did it?
Damn.
What did I get?
I'm...
I'm the master builder, guys.
I like how...
I was the...
Everybody else has two things...
And I have 25.
I...
I started it.
Yep.
I started...
Hi.
Nice.
Let's go.
We can do this.
We can make it to 100.
I believe in us.
Guys, just upgrade your mortar!
Where's my cursor?
Where did it go?
Guys, I lost it again.
Oh, there it is.
I found it.
Guys, upgrade your mortar, guys!
I know you're here!
Upgrade him!
Guys, hurry!
Why did no one up at the bottom?
Oh, wait.
They're mine.
No, they're not!
See?
They're not mine.
They're player 4.
Whoever player 4 is.
They're not mine.
I know, because I only put out...
Guys, I would know which one's mine, because I literally only put out two characters.
Ice Monkey, and helicopters.
Can you gift him money?
Um, he's gotta earn it, like the rest of us.
Um, why would I give him money when he can earn it like the rest of us?
What's your money?
Like the...
Tote.
That's dope.
Oh, hey, um...
All that I'm saying...
The gaming icon gives them money?
Which one?
I don't know how to give them money.
This?
Oh!
Who was it?
Who needed money?
Not me, I have plenty of money.
Okay, this is player four.
Who the fuck is player four?
Player four, use your money!
Player four, you have enough money to spend it.
Look at that, look at him, he's so rich!
Spend your money right now, player four!
There we go, good job!
Player two, player two is fine.
He doesn't need money.
He's fine, we can get...
He's okay, guys.
See, look at him.
I guess I could give him a little bit of money, or...
There we go.
See, look at that.
I gave him a little bit.
There we go.
Oh yeah, don't say I didn't do nothing for people.
Jesus Christ, what's going on?
What's going on on my screen?
Okay, what does it look like when...
Okay, everything looks normal now.
Okay.
Okay, that looks a lot better.
I have to actually see what's going on.
Yeah, like, there was too much flashing lights.
Get a submarine?
What's that?
Does it sound like something that can fly?
I don't know.
That doesn't fly.
Okay, the bit rate's back.
Oh my god, we're almost there.
Guys, we're almost at 90!
All right, we did it.
All right.
Oh my god, guys, we're at round 90.
Guys, we're gonna make it!
We're gonna make it to 100!
Oh my god, 91.
Okay, don't worry, I'll send in...
I'll send in the troops.
I'll send in the Marines!
All right, everybody's fully upgraded, right?
I think so.
Yeah, I upgraded everybody instantly.
The lag is...
Yes, it's right.
No, no, it's fine!
It's fine, it's fine.
Look, we're making it.
Look, I'm slowing everything down.
See, look at that.
They just instantly disappear.
Look at that.
They literally just disappear out of everywhere.
I don't even know where they went.
Oh my god.
Like, they die so fast, they just snap out of existence.
There's no way I can lose, guys.
Look at all these abilities I have.
It's so laggy!
We have to make it to 100!
There'll be five.
The moment we make it to 100, it's over.
We're free!
I hear ya.
Don't worry, I have so many freezes.
I don't know what they do, but look at it go.
Look at it though, we're all dancing.
95, 95, five more to go!
I need a 50-90 for this game.
Guys, this is me turning the effects all the way down too, by the way.
I don't know what it's gonna be like if the effects were all the way up.
Alright, 96.
We're almost there.
I'm freezing everything.
Oh my god, it's just all air balloons.
It's just literally all air balloons.
It's all...
Oh, and they're dead.
How do they die so fast?
I can barely see it.
They just get snapped out of existence.
Alright, nice.
Alright, 97.
Okay.
97.
Alright.
We freeze them.
Oh, now he's dead?
Come on, keep freezing.
I'm freezing him!
I'm doing everything I can!
I'm still freezing him!
Oh my god!
Okay, don't worry.
He just instant dies from here.
Level 37, nice.
Alright.
Oh, here it is.
Here's the run killer.
We're gonna make it, boys.
We're gonna make it!
Oh, I pressed the wrong button.
Don't worry!
98 is nothing!
I'm setting men down right now!
My men are coming down!
There we go!
Oh!
And they're dead.
See?
I told you!
Wait!
90...
98 was supposed to be hard?
That was so easy!
Look at that!
What the fuck are you talking about?
It's big, slow...
Okay, it's big airship time.
Oh my god!
There it is!
You know what that means?
What does this look like?
Oh my god!
Okay, let's do...
Let's do five.
You know what?
No, that's like too much.
I have...
Let's just get rid...
I saw...
I saw it for one second and I was like...
That's good enough.
That's good enough for me.
Wait, we did it!
That's it!
Yeah!
We did it, everyone!
Alright, goodbye guys.
Now that we beat 100...
07...
07 to the crew.
We did it.
Easiest...
I told you.
Ice monkey build was it.
I told you that was the biz.
We did it.
All us guys.
No extra help needed.
No!
Hahaha!
We carried this entire crew ourselves.
Look at that.
You're welcome, everybody.
You're welcome.
I couldn't have done it without ice monkey.
I...
Hahaha!
GG, everyone!
GG!
Hahaha!
We were so good.
Wait, everybody left.
Oh, shit!
The good...
Hahaha!
Wait!
I gotta leave!
I gotta leave before I die!
I lose!
I got...
I like how...
You can tell who left when everything was just gone.
And I was like, wait a minute.
I'm starting to lose.
What happened?
Oh my...
Oh my god.
Play for three...
Almost three hours.
It did not feel like three hours.
I got too absorbed into...
I can tell why this game is addicting now.
I...
Hahaha!
Oh man!
That was fun!
Hope you guys had fun watching me, uh...
Play at Bloons.
That was pretty addicting.
I can...
I...
Seriously, I just passed by...
So fast, too.
Um...
Yeah, now I know why they made six of them.
And why it was a very popular pay-to-win game on mobile.
Hahaha!
But I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching.
I do have another stream later today.
Um...
In an hour and a half with Girls Frontline, too.
I saw a lot of people were actually really excited about it.
Um...
I didn't realize how popular they were in general.
Like, so many people were like, Oh, I don't watch Yoki, but I love Girls Frontline!
I can't wait to check out the stream!
So yeah!
I'm super excited to check it out.
This will be my first time trying out the game.
I have no knowledge of the game whatsoever.
Um...
I just know it's like a gacha game.
And that's really it.
So I'm looking forward to trying it out.
Uh...
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna rest a little bit before my second stream.
Um...
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
You get that blood running.
Uh...
And you stay up for me.
Head to bed.
Cause...
You deserve it.
Or go to come and see the sponsor.
As a, uh...
Sponsor stream.
I'm gonna raid the sponsor waiting room, too.
Alright, everybody.
Bye, guys!
Bye!